what is your definition Rich of a high
value man because we hear that term all
the time
again I think it's that whole you know
you can't call yourself an alpha you
can't call yourself a high value man
either
um Society determines your value and
you'll know your value is high if you
have women fawning over you if you have
men that are demanding your attention or
your assistance or your health sort of
thing
um it's one of those things that you'll
come to a realization when it hits you
it's like taking a frying pan to the
forehead you know it's there
um a lot of guys will use that term but
I'm a high value man I think there's a a
video clip or a short clip somewhere on
one of my YouTube channels you know I'm
doing this uh consult you know with this
guy who's calling in on one of my
podcasts and he says well I'm a high
value man and I said no no no and you
know this cat was you know he was a
decent looking guy but he was he was he
was out of shape I saw that he had this
uh Amish looking beard you know like it
didn't really suit his face his wife
wouldn't let him watch my videos he said
something along the lines of you know
know uh you know my wife saw one of your
videos and she said uh uh yeah I don't
want you watching that guy anymore you
know sort of thing that's not a high
value guy that's that's a beta that's
under the control you know without his
wife and when you said when you said in
response well she's really not gonna
like this one then is she right yeah
yeah I'm sure he I'm sure she's seen
that by now but that's but that's also
the delusion that men are under too
because men have become feminized
they've been taught to behave like like
defective women today right that's where
you get these softer weaker men that are
adopting the the characteristics and the
personality traits of women one of the
things that I've noticed recently is a
lot of men will start conversations with
I feel like
okay and that's what almost all women
start conversation well I just feel like
my Notch count doesn't really matter
Becky because my pass is in the past it
doesn't matter how many guys I banged
and I just feel like that I should be
accepted for who I am and a man should
take me in my you know five kids from
five different fathers you know and just
adopt us all sort of thing that's like
that's how women talk that's how they
think that's how they rationalize things
with their feelings and you'll start to
notice and your audience will notice
this too I'm sorry I've done this to you
but I've changed the scope of your
understanding in conversations now but
you're going to hear a lot of guys start
conversations with I just feel like
and leave the feelings to the women men
are rational deductive thinkers right
like that's how we solve problems so you
will notice this and the guys that are
thinkers the guys that are you know at
the Forefront of this sort of thing
they'll start conversations with I think
or my experience is you know something
along the lines of that so you'll see
that more and more it's it's just the
you know the point
in time in history that we're at you
know we have weaker men the
pussification of the West is a real
thing and they don't want a strong
resilient independent Society they want
the society they want soft men so they
can be controlled exactly rich and I
talk about that a lot I do mostly
politics and culture on this program we
talk about the uh the covid mandates the
mask mandates all of that that happened
and the rich down down where I am there
were mask mandates in place for about
two years I walked freely wherever I
wanted to without a mask on my face I do
not want the government in my life the
government has no right to dictate to me
my freedoms but so many men out there
they caved they caved and they you still
see them driving alone in their car with
a mask on and and I'm thinking of myself
Rich our ancestors used to hunt bears
with sticks
and now we have people driving around in
cars by themselves with masks on and I
feel and and you I'm sure you'll agree
with me this is the one time in history
right now to where our country our world
our our entire system is being run by
the softest beta uh most pussified men
that ever walk the face of the Earth and
why did we allow that to happen
I don't think that we allowed it to
happen it's you know it's a whole
boiling of a frog in a pot it doesn't
know it's being boiled because it
happens so slowly
um the the systematic pacification of
the western male is uh it's a
combination of a number of things right
culture
um even even even popular like like
sitcoms
um when I was a kid watching uh TV shows
dad would come home he was a strong
masculine figure you know he would run
that like that was kind of the Leave it
to Beaver sort of era yeah around then
and there was a few sitcom shows that
followed that but even like The Cosby
Show uh home improvement with Tim Taylor
uh the guy like the Father the husband
was always the butt of all jokes he was
an incompetent idiot that couldn't get
anything done that was used for comedic
purposes during the show so we've so
we've grown up on a steady diet of uh
you know women are these brilliant
things that that should be cherished in
worship and men are bumbling idiots
you'll see it in advertisements for
commercials you'll see it everywhere you
go when you see it you'll see it in TV
shows and movies I'll sometimes sit back
and I'll throw on a Netflix or a
streaming show Teddy and I'll watch it
for five or ten minutes and if it starts
feeding you know like the pussification
of the West narratives sort of thing
it's not you know straight up and up
sort of thing there's no man's man
character in the show exactly I'll just
turn it off I'm not gonna watch that
[__] I'm not gonna you know have anybody
in my household watch that kind of
garbage so that gets turned off
immediately the other thing too is most
people don't know this but testosterone
levels have been dropping in men
dramatically over the last UH 60 70
years
um I had a guy on a podcast recently uh
Dr Anthony J he wrote a book called
extra Generation
Um and he he basically talks about how
environmental estrogens have slowly been
polluting us with things like toiletries
the foods that we eat the packaging
um the agricultural pesticides and are
put on food that we consume that act
like estrogen in our body they even
allow estrogens to remain in the city
water lines Teddy wow women on birth
control they're urinating out hormones
all the time and there's a lot of women
on birth control in many places in the
world birth control is free you know
women can just get it for free you know
from the government and that all ends up
in the sanitary system and you know the
sanitary pipes and you know facilities
are real good at removing particles you
know large particles anything that you
know could be bacteria that they can
neutralize but hormones are tiny and
they don't take them out they can take
them out but they don't take them out I
actually asked them in one of the
podcasts you know I said do these people
at the facilities know that there's
estrogen in the water and he said yeah
they know so they know what's in the
water they're not taking it out so as
you're drinking tap water you're
increasing the estrogen level in your
body and you're reducing the
testosterone levels you can get that out
of your water if you use a five-stage
reverse osmosis water filtration system
by the way
um but I mean like even well water if
you're in farm country and farmers are
using pesticides like atrazine that's
gonna you know run off into your well
water and you're probably drinking
atrazine which is going to you know
convert into estrogen in your body so
there's a lot of problems out there that
that compound this narrative that's
that's softening and weakening the
Western male and and Rich you you
touched on a book the history of
marriage and how things were completely
different
150 years ago and it has slowly uh
gotten to the point to where it is today
and and I looked back and I said this a
while ago Rich that I did not start to
notice it
until the early 2000s when you had that
TV show uh Queer Eye For The Straight
Guy right and
you know everybody prancing around you
know going to hair salons to get their
tips frosted and again like you say a
touch with your feelings and I think
that really ramped up the onslaught uh
of the attack on masculinity going going
back the past 20 years rich or 30 yeah
20 30 years what major things have you
seen in the past 20 30 years that have
really amped up this Onslaught on the
masculinity attack
man well you know we talked about Esther
generation you know we talked about
media Hollywood
um culture is pussified men I think you
know the whole scandemic was an
interesting test wasn't it because yes
it was how many how many men leaders of
their household wore face diapers and
complied and Shook and took experimental
vaccinations that the government said
were completely safe that we're now
seeing were not effective and aren't
completely safe it you know I find it
fascinating that they're able to develop
a uh a world-saving cure like a
vaccination and something like six to
eight months but we've had cancer
forever you know they haven't been able
to figure out how to solve that one yet
sort of thing so it's like you know you
just sort of have to step back and take
a look at the code in The Matrix and see
what's going on out there and ask
yourself questions and say you know okay
that's that's an interesting story now
let's take a look at it from a different
perspective but people don't do that
anymore they don't use critical thinking
to solve anything because they use
groupthink now right you know we just oh
everybody's doing this I'll just start
doing that myself as well there is an
interesting experiment that was done I
wish I could recall the name of it but
they used a dental office and what they
did was everybody in the dental office
was a paid actor and you know they had
everything there the coffee tables with
you know with the magazines and the
water thing and the TV you know with the
news on and the receptionist sitting
behind the counter with all the you know
the files and everything but behind them
and the one person that came in it was
their first time there at the dental
office and they thought they were going
in for treatment what they did was every
couple of minutes they would play a loud
beep so they'd be sitting there doing
their things beep and everybody would
just put down their magazine not look at
the TV and just stand up and do this and
I saw that I saw that yeah yeah and it
and it took this individual that was the
placed object there you know like the
test subject I think it was twice and
then by the third time they got up and
they followed over didn't ask any
questions why are we doing this like
nobody would talk they would just stand
up and sit down and get and comply and
it was like you know it only took a
couple stabs at it so I think that
I don't know look is there some room
full of power for people that figure
this out and they're like you know let's
[__] Society I don't even know if I'd
give him that much credit I just think
that's probably just the direction that
we're going in and there's some
realization there that a softer weaker
Society is a little bit more
controllable than one that's got
independence you know uh thinking skills
critical thinking skills that's just the
way that human beings are and you know
this trend that's moved away from
um you know the nuclear family because
you were talking about uh the history of
marriage the the tldr version of that of
that book is that you know the history
of marriage is that people got married
for the acquisition of in-laws they
didn't get married for love they didn't
get married to have kids like that was
all a byproduct of it you know sort of
thing in some cases in other cases maybe
not but it was I had stuff my family had
stuff you know I got a doctor in my
family I got a guy that's good with law
enforcement you got a guy in your family
that's a dentist you've got a bunch of
land that we can Farm the acquisition of
in-laws allowed you to
um form a stronger more productive
family unit and you would rely on each
other to get stuff done now the state's
the head of the household anybody that's
gotten through the divorce machine
realizes how little to no control you
have over your own life as a man and a
father if you have children uh over the
direction the future of your life right
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full-length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out